covid has had a huge impact on the life
chances of young people education work
family it means millions have missed out
and it seems those in the north of the
country have been particularly affected
a disturbing port by my next guest shows
that it could affect those young people
throughout their lives and i'm joined
now by professor kate pickett of york
university good morning professor
pickett
what were you trying to discover with
the work that you did here
well what we were trying to do was not
so much discover but synthesize like put
together
all of the evidence about how children
in the north were
disadvantaged compared to their peers in
the south and the rest of england before
covert but also to look at the
disproportionate impact that covid has
had
on children in the north so there's not
a lot in this report that's brand new i
mean a lot of us have known much of this
evidence before but it's the first time
it's all been put together
and together it makes a really
disturbing picture
so what what are the headlines on that
picture what what did uh putting the
evidence together tell you that um
you know we ought to be concerned about
well it highlights how disadvantaged
children in the north are in terms of
their mental health their physical
health their education their life
chances even before covert and how
disproportionately affected by the
pandemic they have been so they've
missed more schooling their mental
health has been worst affected their
physical activity levels are lower
and we've also been able to put a cost
on this so we can see that unless we
mitigate against that extra damage that
extra impact
we will see a scar across the life
chances of those children and that will
affect their lifelong productivity and
the productivity of the north of england
in general so if we want to really you
know do the best for our economy for
leveling up and for individual children
then we need to invest where it's needed
most
so to be clear on this uh graph that
we're seeing just uh
to make sure i understand it properly
what we're saying what you're saying is
that in lifetime earnings
children at school now can expect to see
something like twelve and a half
thousand uh a penalty if you like
because penalty yes
exactly
okay um
but you also had some data i think about
the
number of months lost uh if you like in
in learning uh advance
that's right so children in the north of
england experienced more restrictions
you know more months of restrictions
than children elsewhere and that
affected their learning and so we find
that they've lost four to five months
more of maths literacy learning than
children elsewhere in england so that
that's a really big loss
what you if you had your your your
weight uh okay pick it um what would you
do to help those children catch up what
can you give me a magic wand okay if
you're giving me a magic wand i would
ask the government to put children and
families at the heart of the leveling up
agenda and target
their investment where it's needed the
most to the most deprived areas and to
the areas most affected by the pandemic
and to invest in early childhood and
they could do things so easily they
could increase child benefit top up the
child aspect of the universal credit
child tax credits um fund family centers
even more than they promised to do in
the budget so it's just a matter of
directing
their investment to the places that need
it the most
let's stick with the uh sky news magic
one for a moment and you've got it
last week we were
in um a town called ghoul on the humber
which is exactly one of the kinds of
places that i think people will be
talking about when they're talking about
leveling up in in practice
what you've just said how would that
make a difference for
a family
in ghoul which currently maybe
somebody's lost their job where they uh
feel that
in jargon they've been left behind what
would they see
that would be different that would help
to close this
gap that you've described
well we know that all parents want to do
the best for their children and if
you're feeling that your children's life
chances are being hampered by poverty
by poor schools by
lack of services that's incredibly
stressful and so i think even
small amounts of investment into into
families livelihoods can really reduce
stress for parents can really impact
things like food security housing
security enabling families to have
the time and the care for their children
and to be able to to nurture them in the
ways that they would most wish to
so
fairly small amounts for families can
make a big difference
um and the kinds of investment that
we're asking for the kinds of
recommendations that we're making in
this report really could tip the balance
between children having the best start
in life or children being
in families where the chronic stress of
poverty is really affecting everybody's
life chances and well-being
the major government player here is uh
the new relatively new secretary of
state for leveling up michael gove um
have you sent the report to him and what
would be your expectation of his
response our report's going to all
relevant ministers and mps and we
already know that there's cross-party
support for for doing something about
the recommendations in this report i
would ask him to come and talk to us
and i would ask him to make sure that
children and families at the heart of
leveling up